so the key when you add fractions is to
what get a common denominator right but
the key to getting a common denominator
is really to figure out what those
denominators are made up of and the way
that we do that is by factoring so let's
go into this first problem and I'll show
you how to work with this so when you
factor this you can see this is going to
be X minus 4x plus 3 now if you need
some help with factoring I'll put a link
to a video that I did talking about
learning how to factor all the different
types that you're likely to encounter in
algebra 1 algebra 2 precalculus etc and
the key then is to factor it so break it
down because then what you can do when
you have it broken down like this is you
can say well I can see that I have an X
minus 4 in this fraction I can see I
have an X minus 4 in this fraction also
an X plus 3 so what I'm missing over
here is X plus 3 so I'm gonna multiply
the denominator by X plus 3 as well as
the numerator by X plus 3 okay whatever
you do to the bottom you wanna do at the
top because really that's multiplying by
1 because anything divided by itself is
1 it doesn't change the value of the
fraction it just changes the way that it
looks so we're going to distribute and
you can see we're getting 2x plus 6 okay
over X plus 3 X minus 4 and then this
one we have plus 5 and it's also over X
minus 4 X plus 3 we have that common
denominator so now what we can do is
just combine the numerators
since they have the same denominator 6
plus 5 is 11 so we get 2x plus 11 all
over X plus 3 X minus 4 now something
you want to watch out for when you're
doing these problems is that you may be
able to reduce further like you might be
able to factor the numerator and then
you can see if any factors in the
numerator cancel with factors in the
denominator so you always want to look
for that let's go to example number 2
see if you can do this one again the key
the first step is to factor that
denominator so you can see what those
denominators are made up both so here
I'm going to do that this comes out to
2x + 1 X and this comes out to negative
7 and positive 1 right because negative
7 X plus 2x gives us negative 5 X so we
can see this denominator is made up of
2x minus 7 times X plus 1 here we've got
a 2x minus 7 but we're missing an X plus
1 so let's multiply the new
and denominator by X plus one so now we
have a common denominator what we're
gonna do now is we're going to
distribute now there's two different
ways to do these problems notice this is
a subtraction problem you can think
about it one of two ways one way that
students do it is they say well instead
of subtracting let me think of this as
adding the opposite then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take this negative
3 I'm going to distribute negative 3
into the parenthesis so that gives us
negative 3x minus 3 the other way to do
it is just to go ahead and leave it as
it was positive 3 distribute the
positive 3 that would be 3x plus 3 but
then when you subtract you want to put
that in parenthesis you want to take it
as a group so it would look like
something like this so then you would
have to distribute the negative but I
think it's easier just if you have just
one term here just like a constant just
think of it as adding the opposite and
distribute that quantity yet that's a
common mistake so make sure you don't
fall for that one right okay so now what
we have is negative 3x minus 3 plus 5x
minus 4 we combine like terms we get 2x
minus 7 so I'm just combining the 5x and
negative 3x the negative 4 negative 3 is
negative 7 and this is all over 2x minus
7 X plus 1 so what do you notice here
this is kind what we were talking about
in the last example notice that the 2x
minus 7 cancels numerator and
denominator we're left with 1 because 1
times anything is itself right so when
there's nothing left in the numerator
that's understood to be a 1 over X plus
1 and that's our